welcome to CBS this morning and that's
where we begin as you wake up this
Democratic presidential race is now a
closed two-man contest after Super
Tuesday last night former Vice President
Joe Biden won nine of yesterday's 14
state primaries completing a remarkable
turnaround from just one week ago
remember that his biggest upset came in
Texas where he overcame the former
frontrunner senator Bernie Sanders
former Mayor Mike Bloomberg and senator
Elizabeth Warren finished far behind
Biden also came from behind it went
Minnesota and Massachusetts while he
swept all the primaries in southern
states Sanders did win three primaries
and he's in a strong position in the
biggest state of all California but this
morning he is trailing Biden in the
delegate race though many of the
delegates from yesterday's races have
not been allocated yet Ed O'Keefe is
covering campaign 2020 and how much did
Super Tuesday change the race what an
incredible night oh Anthony incredible
certainly one way to put it look Joe
Biden wakes up today in a far stronger
position than anyone would have thought
just a few days ago but senator Sanders
by no means is out of this the state
with the biggest delegate haul of the
night California is leaning towards him
look at this 33% for Bernie Sanders 24%
for Jill Biden only 51% of the vote in
they're going to keep counting in the
Golden State with Biden substantial wins
across the rest of the country
California's largest delegate count
might not prove to be a safety net the
safety net that Bernie Sanders was
looking for super Tuesday jolted former
Vice President Joe Biden's presidential
campaign back to life as he swept
victories from New England to the south
and the Midwest Biden even won in Texas
despite being outspent by senator Bernie
Sanders by millions given the spread of
support Sanders will still pick up many
of the Lone Star state's delegates you
cannot beat Trump with the same old same
old kind of politics nearly half of the
voters who made up their minds in the
last few days voted for Biden
[Music]
signaling that is Saturday win in South
Carolina and the endorsements from
former rivals could have made the
difference what we need is a new
politics that brings working-class
people into a political movement which
brings young people into our political
movement
and which in November will create the
highest voter turnout in American
political history but that increased
turnout last night actually came in
states that Biden won for example in
Virginia turnout jumped by more than
500,000 votes from the 2016 Democratic
primary
while Biden continued to lead among
African Americans and voters forty five
years and over Sanders earned more
support from Latinos and voters under
the age of 45 we are putting together an
unprecedented grassroots
multi-generational both high racial
movement the numbers didn't look good
for senator Elizabeth Warren who
finished third behind Biden and Sanders
in her home state of Massachusetts I'm
in this race because I believe I will
make the best president of the United
States former New York Mayor Michael
Bloomberg skipped the early primaries to
concentrate on the Super Tuesday states
spending more than 230 million of his
own dollars on advertising there but it
didn't pay off he came up short in
states like North Carolina and Virginia
and only won the u.s. territory of
American Samoa in just three months
we've gone from 1% of the polls to being
a contender for the Democratic
nomination for president as for what's
next Bloomberg is back in New York today
and his campaign manager said they'll
reassess going forward but as of now
they're committed to staying in the race
saying from senator Elizabeth Warren
Tony could still be a busy day all right
I thank you very much as always the
numbers tell the story so let's dig a
little bit deeper into those numbers
with CBS News elections and surveys
director Anthony Silvano Anthony good
morning or night for you yeah let's talk
about two of the states where the
results have not come in we have made a
call yet that is California and Maine
how are they looking
Maine very close California is leaning
to Bernie Sanders he has got the most
delegates that we've allocated out of
there so far but I still think there's
about two million mail ballots left to
come in we'll see what happens but he is
gonna get more doubts remarkable that
it's even close in California Sanders is
going to run away
so Joe Biden big night for him how did
he pull it off and were you even
surprised Anthony I sat there watching
as the numbers came in going what is
happening I haven't seen anything like
it when we look at like Bob Schieffer
yeah gentle Bob there yeah but look when
we saw those exit polls the first thing
we noticed was the late deciders people
who told us that they made up their
minds who to vote for in the last couple
of days now that's after Budaj edge and
Klobuchar had dropped out and endorsed
Joe Biden well all those folks sometimes
up to half the Elector in places like
Virginia they all switch to Joe Biden so
he took that support plus he got strong
support from the african-american vote
you know and support from people who
thought he could beat Donald Trump and
that just really pushed him in it was
like two different elections in effect
cuz you had the early voters on the one
hand and then the decided in the last
couple of days that's right that's right
and so what you saw I was in places
where they cast a lot of mail ballots
like a California like a Texas you might
have expected Bernie Sanders to do okay
but then those those same day voters the
ones who turned out last night yesterday
did people's perception of Joe Biden
change I had people saying I'm still in
line and I'm still trying to decide is
that what happened
he still has high favorables he did have
high favorables but the biggest thing is
people decided that they wanted somebody
they could be Donald Trump even more
than someone who agreed with them on the
issue quickly next week what are we
looking towards next week I think the
big big play is to Michigan
that's probably well though where
they'll go it's a battleground state
they'll try to argue that that's where
they can turn out Democrats and maybe
look forward to November we'll do this
all again then